[Music]
hi thanks for joining us at Google Cloud
next
today we'll go through how Google Cloud
optimizes infrastructure for your unique
workload
I'm Chelsea chop product manager for
AIML and HPC on Google cloud and I'm
joined by ruin Hess a group product
manager of storage and you'll hear from
him in a little bit
today we have two main topics we'll go
through announcements in compute engine
as well as storage
so let's dive in to talk through more on
compute engine
a few years ago we introduced VM
families and they were created to be
optimized for all specific workloads so
let's do a quick refresher of each
family
starting on the left the general purpose
we have cost optimized or efficient VMS
for E2 they provide up to a 31 cost
savings compared to our original N1
machines they provide reliable
performance across Intel and AMD and
they can be provisioned with custom
machine types or cmts to only pay for
what you need
going one to the right we have balanced
or N2 and n2d providing a balance
between customization performance and
TCO
they provide the widest feature set and
can also be put provisioned with custom
machine types a quick little reminder
for you the n2d denotes AMD and N2 is
Intel based
moving another one to the right we have
a newest family and that is Tau VMS and
they were introduced last year and
provide the best performance per dollar
and are optimized for scale at workloads
when we introduced how VMS last year it
was on the third generation AMD epic
Milan processor and earlier this year we
launched t2a our first arm instance and
we'll dive into more on t2a in a minute
now for workload optimize starting on
the right
we have compute optimized which provides
the highest performance consistency CPUs
on compute engine and this is best
suited for your high-end web and app
serving gaming or even near HPC
workloads and I'm really excited to
announce one of our first third
generation VMS with you C3
moving one over we have memory optimized
which provides the most memory and
compute engine and is best suited for
your largest databases such as sap Hana
or Windows databases
and to round our workload optimize Fleet
we have accelerator optimized VMS with
high-end Performance gpus Based on
Nvidia ampere a100 tensor core gpus
we'll also get to another exciting
announcement in our A2 VMS as well
now let's dive into our recent launches
starting on the left for general purpose
we have talviums
earlier this year we announced the
addition of the Tau family with
arm-based VMS and they're now generally
available in Google Cloud extending that
rich choices that we already have to
offer with Intel and AMD
you can now use these VMS in select
regions in North America Europe and Asia
and these VMS support key Google
products like Google kubernetes engine
in addition there's support for broad
ecosystem of operating systems databases
programming languages and so many other
tools as well next up in our compute
optimized VM family we're excited to
introduce C3 our newest machine series
powered by fourth generation Intel Xeon
scalable processors or codename Sapphire
Rapids C3 is more than just another CPU
update this is the first VM built on our
next Generation platform architecture
powered by Google Cloud's custom Intel
infrastructure Processing Unit or an ipu
this ipu is the outcome of a deep
multi-year collaboration between Google
cloud and Intel
C3 also features new 200 gigabytes low
latency networking as well as high
performance i o products Cloud hyperdisc
which you'll soon hear more from ruin
about
contact your sales team to join in on
our private preview
because our clusters can be scaled and
paralyzed more densely we're seeing
customers and partners like ansys
Snapchat and parallel Works completing
jobs must much faster and also boosting
their productivity
Snapchat or snap was able to obtain a 20
increase in performance over C2 for a
key workload
parallel Works does vital development
towards building of weather ready Nation
including noaa's multi-cloud r d
Computing environment they were able to
achieve a 10x faster results running
morph on C3
and ansys a leader in engineering
simulation was able to see a 3X
performance gain and C3 over C2 running
their Flagship mechanical products
including ansys fluent ansys mechanical
and lsdina due to the higher memory
bandwidth and lower Network latency that
you get with C3
so let's move on to accelerator optimize
in our accelerator optimize VM portfolio
it's a VM that is optimized to run the
Nvidia a100 gpus we're really excited to
announce today the A2 Ultra GPU VM
instance which is based on the Nvidia
a100 80 gigabyte GPU
this is best suited for largest models
with massive data tables like deep
learning recommendation models
the A180 gigabyte reaches up to 1.3
terabytes of unified memory per node and
delivers up to a 3X throughput increase
over the original a140 gigabyte
for HPC applications with largest data
sets the A180 gigabytes additional
memory was able to deliver up to a 2X
Inc throughput increase with Quantum
espresso a material simulation
on a big data analytics Benchmark a 180
gigabytes delivered insights with the to
a 2X increase over the a140 gigabyte
this makes it ideally suited for your
merging workloads with exploding data
sets
and we hear from our customers and users
all the time that their AI demands
purpose-built infrastructure for them to
be successful
AI Singapore is a national program in AI
supported by their National Research
Foundation and hosted by the National
University of Singapore they were able
to reduce a large language model
processing time by 40 percent and also
gain a 50 increase on tax generation
throughput over the A2 Mega GPU shapes
based off the original a140 gigabyte
this allow other teams to experiment
faster with increased productivity
and I'm also just excited to share that
neuro is looking forward to
experimenting with our purpose-built
hardware for their platform
now I'll hand it off to ruin to talk
about new announcements in storage
thanks so much Chelsea happy to be here
over the years we've launched a lot of
performance and feature improvements to
persistent disk
and while we're happy with where we're
going with persistent disk we've also
taken the time to step back and think a
bit about what is block storage on the
cloud really ideally look like
from customer conversations
three areas quickly crystallized
ideally block storage should be
dynamically provisioned tuned to
specific performance and capacity needs
and decoupled from instance type and
size
customers should be able to dynamically
change performance when requirements
change
also block storage should be full
spectrum meaning that it should cover
all the core cloud workloads and that
for each workload it should cover the
entire Spectrum without efficiency or
TCO clips
and then finally block storage ideally
should be managed at scale
with aggregate storage management
including capacity pooling and with
policy-based management
and ideally with workload awareness
allowing you to set performance
requirements to the in the workloads
context rather than tactically at the
disk level
following these insights we set out to
build Google's next Generation block
storage and we're now introducing Google
Cloud hyperdisc
hyperdisc is built to leverage our new
ipu-based architecture it offloads and
dynamically scales out storage
processing
and by decoupling block storage from the
VM hyperdisc allows you to tune easily
and dynamically to storage to your
workload achieving high performance
higher flexibility and higher efficiency
to bring all these capabilities to you
Google cloud hypertisk is an entirely
new portfolio
hyperdisc balanced is our new general
purpose volume type the best fit for
most workloads it covers a broad range
of workloads offering up to 150 000 iops
and 2.4 gigabytes a second of throughput
it's joined on the high end by hyperdisc
extreme our new premium skew focusing on
the highest performance databases with
explicit performance slas and up to 320
000 iops
for cost sensitive throughput oriented
workloads we have hyperdisc throughput
with up to three gigabytes a second and
also performance and capacity
provisioning separately
so all of these cues have capacity and
performance provisioned separately and
dynamically performance decoupled from
instance types and up to 512 terabytes
in capacity all of them will be
available for compute engine and gke
and all of them will also be available
in hypertisk storage pools where you can
manage at scale within provisioning data
reduction and policy based management
let's have a look at what this looks
like
with an actual case study
this is the case study of the steps at a
high level that you might step through
when planning a SQL Server instance
today constraints of how performance and
capacity management works leads to
complicated balancing act when you try
to meet the requirements of the workload
capacity and performance sizing
frequency takes weeks and you need a
detailed understanding of the workload
to do this well
finally mistakes are costly and can
require downtime to fix
hyperdisc allows you to tune performance
to the workload without instance
restrictions you can size capacity
freely and have actual usage determine
consumption without excessive planning
and hardcore gymnastics
and performance can get changed at any
time if requirements change
all of this leads to dramatic real world
impact simpler deployment and management
more efficient use of resources and an
ability to dynamically adjust to
changing requirements at any time
so key three key aspects help you
optimize TCO for storage intensive
workloads with hyperdisc you'll be able
to choose instance size based on
workload needs resulting in smaller
instances you'll be able to provision
only the capacity and performance needed
for workloads resulting in lessover
provisioning and for workloads with
predictable demand patterns we can
further optimize with Dynamic
provisioning if for example your
workload has a peak that's associated
with end-of-quarter reporting you can
adjust it with Dynamic provisioning for
that period alone and then scale back as
needed
overall we estimate that for common
storage intensive workloads you'll see
an average of 50 lower TCO with
hyperdisc
we're very excited about hyperdisc and
look forward to making it available in
preview later this year
we have some great sessions for you at
next this year mod 103 covers the top 10
ways to lower your costs on Google Cloud
mod 107 covers how to protect your
infrastructure with a cloud environment
built to attack today's insecurity
challenges and mod 300 is about
leveraging AI infrastructure to optimize
cost performance
from Chelsea and me thank you for
joining our session we hope you enjoyed
the rest of next
[Music]